FEMA administrator Brock long updated
President Trump in the oval office
yesterday as tropical storm Michael
moved inland administrator long joins us
now from the agency's National Response
Coordination Center in Washington with
the latest on the federal response
good morning administrator this was a
powerful and strong fast-moving storm
what has FEMA been able to assess with
regards to the damage well last night we
were able to mobilize some
search-and-rescue teams into some of the
hardest hit areas between Panama City
Beach and Apalachicola but where we like
everybody are anxious for daylight to be
able to methodically move through and is
move as quickly as we can to fully
estimate what just what what's passed
through but the storms continues to
batter South Carolina and North Carolina
unfortunately I mean we're going to see
you know potentially nine inches of rain
in North Carolina as it exits out today
so we're trying to move as quickly as we
can and obtain access and search and
rescues are real focused right now and
have they begun yet the search and
rescue efforts yeah we were able to get
teams in last night you know to do
limited search and rescue but today we
will bring the full force to the federal
government in as much as we can to help
our state and local partners we
officially know of two deaths do you
know of any more not at this point but
you know unfortunately time will tell as
to the true
the true death toll any time we lose one
life it's it's it's a life to many but
unfortunately in these types of things
as we go through and sift through damage
ultimately those who didn't heed the
warning particularly like around the
Mexico Beach area we typically see
deaths deaths climb unfortunately
especially with a storm like this only
two days for people to prepare and
evacuate
rough long thank you thank you